if the constants of the universe
gravitational speed of light whatever
we're all tiny tiny bit different like
different one part in a billion or
something maybe in our daily lives we
would not notice but over the history of
the universe things would be so
fundamentally changed that our
existences would just not be the same
yeah or we wouldn't exist at all
[Music]
this is star talks sports edition we're
gonna do cosmic queries today the grab
bag version I got with me my co-host of
course Chuck Nice Chuck hey hey what's
up Neil Doug Gary O'Reilly former Soccer
Pro how you doing Gary I'm good now this
is Cosmic Ray's grab bag which takes us
to a broader stretch of the geekosphere
than normally I can handle all by myself
and so guys we brought in the big guns
for this and who would that be the one
and only Charles Lou my friend in
college yes welcome back we need the
crowd noise
Charles all hail the geek in Chief
returning Champion
Steel champion
thank you it's such a pleasure to be
back thanks for having me and to put
this in context the geek Spectrum the
geekosphere no knows no bounds in its
extremities so yes I'm card carrying
geek and I'm proud of it and I can hold
my own on the street but
if Charles Lou walks in the house in the
room
now we entered the multi-giga verse
we got Neil and Chuck Lou oh my gosh so
so Charles you are a professor of
astronomy and physics at uh City
University of Staten Island in New York
that's correct is that fair enough and
do they still give you uh administrative
duties now or are you yes yes
regrettably or happily I'm currently
chair of my department oh wow yeah sorry
to hear that yes no you know it's a
double-edged sword on the one hand yes
there's a lot of paper these days
electrons I guess that one has to push
that one wishes one does not have to
push but on the other hand you get a
chance to really enact change yeah you
know the the 21st century classroom be
what it is you can design curriculum and
move things along better and so I I
really welcome The Challenge and and I'm
very fortunate too that that my
colleagues are great uh there's not a
jerk or a dork among them which and
sometimes
departments cannot post
I really want to look up the origin of
the double-edged sword analogy this is a
metaphor because you know when it comes
to killing people I want a double-edged
sword
not necessarily use it no why why
wouldn't you think about the Scimitar
okay it's a curved block I know it's
heavy on one side right there's a result
the front side can be very very sharp
sharp and meanwhile you have much more
Force going that way and then you poke
in the other direction so not having the
blade actually gives you an advantage
because you have a strength of striking
One Direction there is a story that goes
that during the Crusades Richard the
lionhearted tried to demonstrate to the
saracen prince that he was going to just
how powerful the Crusaders were he took
his two-sided sword and severed an iron
bar with a single stroke because of his
great power
and the saracen prince then came back
brought his Scimitar took a feather
pillow right and sliced my pillow
exactly in half right with the Scimitar
you can't do that with a double-edged
sword but you can't do that with again
some knife so
that Prince Charis is not that
impressive
and it wasn't a my pillow pillow because
I mean let's be real
why can't a double-edged sword cut a
pillow in half
the double-edged sword could cut a
pillow in half but it was not built to
cut a pillow in half and as a result was
built for strength and power but there
was no subtlety to it right not not
Precision no Precision no it was the
Broad Sword and it was meant to it was
meant to be used to fight against
soldiers or Knights In Chain male armor
that's so therefore the Scimitar is not
going to poke a hole through if I can't
cut through the armor I'll just break
your arm right pretty much pretty much
what it was but what the Scimitar can do
is basically scalpel things surgically
remove Limbs and things uh digits in
such a way that you can be as armored as
you want but you still can't do what you
want to do see but here's where I uh
where I go back to my point why not just
have a double-edged scimitar
because of the second Edge because the
second Edge reduces the ability of the
first Edge it's a trade-off between one
side and the other
okay well you're a real know-it-all
ain't you I know
guilty is charged sir Lord nice you know
you should be on our podcast you know
yeah okay
that was good all right so we got we got
questions from our patreon members and
this is a grab bag so it's anything in
sports right science um I'd say I think
it's I think you just end that sentence
that it's anything it's anything okay
let's go with it this is sports edition
though so we can put a sports spin on it
so Chuck and Gary you got the questions
but bring it on and I'll help out like
when it's my turn or when I think I can
help but you'll be involved I guarantee
you generally I am unnecessary in the
presence of Charles I'm not worthy all
right well let's let's kick off the
first one Dan Rez and thank you to all
our patreon patrons for involving
themselves in our requested questions so
here we go I have another question
because this is one of several that Dan
decided he'd drop into our inbox if time
is a constant but is affected in a way
by gravity is there theoretically a way
to manipulate time if gravity waves can
affect how time moves and speed can make
time move either faster or slower
depending on Vantage and he says in
brackets I guess
is there a way obviously theoretically
to manipulate time also is there a
correlation in size and time let's say
hypothetically there's an object or
being that is bigger than the universe
itself would time act differently due to
the larger mass and would this thing
experience time as we do and does the
fact that the size difference allows for
faster movement also perception of time
to said thing or being now that's the
end of the show because that question is
particularly
there's no more time left with time
we're out of time
just out of curiosity is time a constant
the way the speed of light is a constant
because that's how you started
I'm going to reshape the question into
something that's one and a half
sentences long and I'm going to send it
to Charles Charles as the as Dan knows
different factors affect the rate of
passage of time we know this sources of
gravity how fast you're moving how much
mass you are so might there be a future
time where we can manipulate these
factors and make time make time do we
become the time overlords and make time
do what we want Doctor Who dance that
was a dope question Dan I just I think
that's what he's after but I've said it
I don't care if that's what he's after
or not that's what he's asking now
that's a great question that's amazing
right well look this is a great question
it's very complicated lots of great
stuff involved here's how I think about
it here's how I approach something like
this time is a dimension right you go
back to the general theory of relativity
time manipulating time is like talking
about manipulating length width or
height in other words we don't
manipulate the dimensions itself we
manipulate where we are in that
Dimension how we travel in that
Dimension which direction we move speed
at which we move things like that so the
answer really you're
combining two different things one is
the idea of time as a dimension and the
idea and the second idea is time as we
experience it as humans or as individual
organisms or things in the universe so
the answer is yes we can absolutely
manipulate how we experience time in the
future uh we if we could for example go
near a black hole uh we would change our
time experience we can manipulate how we
fast we move through space you know
length width and height in the same way
we can manipulate how fast we move
through time just by picking up our
speed getting close to the speed of
light we know that there's this
phenomenon called time dilation the
important thing to think about is what
are you trying to do are you trying to
change the dimension of time itself or
are you trying to change what we are
experiencing or what others are
experiencing in the form of time this
laughter thing is certainly doable given
the right technology but boy does the
technology have to be pretty darn
Advanced so what would happen is if we
do Master it you could have a whole
other set of people that we might call
Time Bandits
name's already been taken Neil sorry
yeah I know maybe yeah some other time
we could think of something or what was
that movie where time was it a commodity
and you could take it or give it to
people do you remember that oh yes
starring uh Justin Timberlake yeah he
was in it and what was the guy from from
uh The Big Bang Theory
um he was in it too the yeah is this the
one where everyone had a set amount of
time to live and the moment your time
ran out you would just tip over until
then you would never age right you never
aged yeah and yeah and you could just
hand the time you could buy it or sell
it yeah get it on the on the black
market right yeah that That's a classic
idea of time you know taking the extreme
of course of time as a resource right if
you talk to say human resource managers
or people who wish to optimize a
corporation or an individual's ability
to get stuff done they think of time as
a resource and say you have 24 hours
each day how do you apportion it to all
the different things you do how do you
make it more efficient things like that
right as a physicist uh you might think
more about time as a dimension uh which
is what Einstein considered as the right
way to think about it but we could put
it in a bottle
time first thing that I'd like to do
Time in a Bottle wow what would you do
what would you do that first thing but
there never seems to be enough time I
was singing do the things right that's
to do the thing yeah well well Time Has
Come Today
at least time is on my side
and time for another question
um look at that and he went so he's
that's why he's the champion look at
that goes out with a little Mick Jagger
on us
all right Samuel Barnett uh greetings
from London that's London England oh uh
uh London Connecticut okay no not to be
mistaken uh a bit of a hypothetical
question given enough advanced
technology would it be possible I think
you're gonna like this uh would it be
possible for an advanced alien
civilization to steal our son before the
other side of the world noticed it was
missing nah great question well they
they have eight minutes to pull off the
world's greatest Heist there you go the
The Solar System's greatest Heist right
yeah yeah but you're exactly right Chuck
you're exactly right it takes eight
minutes for the information that the sun
is gone to reach the Earth the thing is
it would take eight minutes plus to get
the information to the Earth that it's
missing but then the side that's facing
away from the earth excuse me the side
of the earth that's facing away from the
Sun at that moment would still know
right away like within moments that it
was missing because of all the different
things it does other than shine right
because of all the different things that
the sun does to the Earth other than
shine first of all the shine is
interesting enough right that each
second the amount of sunshine that hits
the Earth uh is equivalent to millions
of atomic bombs right and as a result
you're you're already removing that heat
and that Heat's going to flow completely
differently than when the sun is shining
equilibrium is completely messed up
right second of all the gravitational
effect is missing immediately so the
entire Earth would start moving thing in
a direction completely different from
what it was doing when it was still in
the sun's gravitational field right so
um it might fly straight off into
another direction right it's like if you
let go of a lasso and you let the string
go and then the thing just goes flying
straight away right you have a brick on
a string or something and you spin it
these moments you let go of a string
that heads off in a straight line all of
the Earth would go at the same time in
that direction and so there's all kinds
of things that would immediately affect
the entire Earth the moment that the
information that the sun is gone reaches
the Earth or maybe we just like finally
get a chance to go make out with Mars
it would be fun except Mars is heading
off in its own Direction
Mars is like I don't want anything to do
with you Earth I'm headed to Venus yeah
yeah all the planets yeah
is there what about uh when you talk
about that flying off in the tangent is
there since Jupiter has so much mass
nowhere near the of the sun is it
possible that we might one planet or two
Planet kind of follow after Jupiter
because of the amount of gravity that it
has excellent question Chuck uh I would
say that you would have to do the
calculation at that precise moment right
because the positions of the plant is
relative to one another keep varying on
a second by second basis they all orbit
at different rates in a different
distances from the Sun but if at the
moment that the sun disappeared the
planets were within Jupiter's sphere of
influence in other words we weren't at
escape velocity with respect to Jupiter
then indeed we would start moving toward
Jupiter and there's a real possibility
that we would wind up orbiting Jupiter
after a long period of migration right
you can picture if we're on one side of
the sun headed to the left and the
Jupiter is on the other side of the Sun
headed or had headed the other way and
then we lose the gravity Jupiter's in
one direction we're in the other so
we're not catching Jupiter at that point
exactly right yeah so right Charles
you'd have to really uh you can do
probably do the math on that and so it
would not get together after that it
would not be too hard to do the math but
it would be uh it would be really cool
actually
I don't want to try it I don't want to
try it my sunband really neat the sun
Bandits
so guys we're gonna take a quick break
when we come back more start talk sports
edition grass bag
Cosmic queries on Star Talk
we're back
sports edition Cosmic queries grab bag
and you know I need help with the grab
bag so we got Charles Liu
with us and by the way Star Talk fans we
retooled the categories of our patreon
membership
and so I want to see what those new
categories are that might uh entice you
if you haven't been a patreon member
before uh this new structure might
resonate with you and of course you'd
find that at patreon.com
StarTalk radio so check that out because
all the questions we were responding to
today are from patreon Members that's
one of the Privileges and one of the
perks all right so stop sending them to
me and join patreon okay stop trying to
stop trying to gain the system game the
system all right and so Gary this is uh
this is star talk sports edition why
don't we get into the sports questions
oh you're so impatient uh we're gonna
get there yay go sports uh segment three
uh yeah but on patreon audience are so
inquisitive the cosmic curiosity is so
deep and intense I felt the need to just
bring that forward and not just hog all
those questions get warmed up with the
actual Universe all right we're going to
go off and do our stretches and all
right let's do it all right next
question up never
Nefertiti yeah okay I might mangle that
one so uh which of the laws of an
interesting question this which of the
laws of physics could you change and
have the least effect on everyday life
oh geez oh oh wow well they're also
interconnected right I mean I I don't
know if you can tweak any one thing and
it not just like totally unraveled the
entire tapestry of the earth and the
world and everything we do yeah I gotta
agree with you Charles on that yeah
they're so interconnected right that if
you change one thing that's the
beginning of the end of everything you
know and love in this world right all
right how about this one let me give you
guys my my example just oh God craps and
Giggles okay for every action there's an
equal and opposite reaction suppose we
made the reaction
opposite but not equal
yes ah well already we in in reality we
have these things called friction and
viscosity right they they dissipate some
of the action when it comes back so to
some extent it is a lesser reaction like
a by a tiny fraction if you take these
dissipated forces into account so maybe
if it were a tiny tiny bit different you
know that's a great point shot it's very
possible that we would not notice so it
would have to be a very small change but
maybe you know if it were at the
99.999999 level true and they just had a
tiny tiny fraction of percent
dissipating we might not be able to tell
on a daily basis because all the rest of
our
um
all the rest of our interactions are so
large compared to that fraction are you
saying Neil and Charles that there is a
natural tolerance albeit a small very
tiny one in the laws of physics or are
they that nothing else you know and that
may be the point right Neil um you're
about to say something along those lines
but if the constants of the universe
gravitational speed of light whatever
we're all tiny tiny bit different like
different one part in a billion or
something maybe in our daily lives we
would not notice but over the history of
the universe things would be so
fundamentally changed that our
existences would just not be the same
yeah or we wouldn't exist at all I'll
give an example there's a there's a
front calculation you do in astrophysics
graduate school and I know the word fun
and calculation are not always in the
same sentence
what you do is you ask yourself suppose
the gravitational constant this was
predicted to Exist by by Isaac Newton
ultimately measured by a fellow named
Cavendish and this gravitational
constant if
if it was slightly different
what effect would it have on for example
the Luminosity of the sun yeah okay
because the sun's energy the the the the
the weight of all the mass and the
pressure and the temperature and the
nuclear reactions all of this when you
do that calculation you find
that the Luminosity of the sun depends
to the seventh power
on the gravitational constant
was a tiny bit higher
than the Luminosity of the sun would be
unacceptably high for anything we enjoy
and love here on Earth in our Goldilocks
zone yeah I remember that calculation
that's fun I know we didn't go to grad
school together but it was it's it's
that mental exercise and and I I
remember thinking wow if we just change
uh the gravitational constant to the
universe by a tenth of a percent then
the surface of the Earth would be
uninhabitable right right right so so so
it's not that everything is in delicate
balance don't think about it in those
terms it's that we are what works with
the properties that exist in this
universe right yes and if you change it
we're not here but maybe something else
would be here in those other under those
other conditions but it wouldn't be
anything we know and love oh well there
you have it so your answer is if it's if
if some butts were candies and nuts
every day would be Christmas so yes
that's exactly what we see you know what
if you want to talk about the Big Bang
Theory that's a great point you know
what Chuck because if the expansion rate
of the universe were different then it
would not affect us
as much during the lifetime of human
beings on the Earth right Neil if if the
Hubble constant were say half of what it
is now or double what it is now then it
wouldn't make a big difference billions
of years from now but at this moment in
the evolution of our society and of
human civilization it would not make
that big of a difference I worry that if
the couple countries were too high then
in the early Universe the matter would
not have coalesced right we would have
expanded and then never formed stars and
galaxies yeah yeah it's a fourth thing
instead of an after thing right and I'm
just saying there are people who get
religious about this and say oh you see
everything is perfectly tuned for us no
we are perfectly to forget that's the
difference
all right oh by the way one other thing
quick quick thing you mentioned the Big
Bang Theory and if and butts were candy
and nuts what was that thing maybe
Christmas every day every Christmas
everything my first of two cameos on the
TV sitcom Big Bang Theory Sheldon
recited that very same poem to my face
oh really yes that's what that's that's
why I know it Neil that's very cool
first time I ever heard that actually
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah all right here
we go let's dive in even deeper Joey
Medici has inquired could a body of Mass
have two different strengths of gravity
think a giant meteor or a planet shaped
like a cone would the end with more mass
have more pull and then finishes up with
thanks okay Charles let me take this one
I got this one go for it so yes first
the answer is yes
um generally when we do calculations we
simplify it and we talk about objects
that are spherically symmetric not only
in in radius but in distance from the
center and so that makes the
calculations come out easy
but geologists geophysicist oil
Prospectors have gravimeters
where they're looking for distortions in
the overall average gravity of the earth
that will tell them where something
heavier than the normal gravity or
lighter than the normal gravity might be
found and that's how they found the
undersea crater
from 65 million years ago which was The
Smoking Gun that took out the dinosaurs
from the asteroid that hit in the
Yucatan Peninsula so if you redistribute
matter the cone is an extreme example
but if you redistribute it in any way we
have the power
to find out where the extra mass
deposits are versus where they're not
and yeah the gravity is not always just
coming quote from the center that's
right no Joey's point is a very good one
and it shows up in other astronomical
activities too so for example when we
try to send spacecraft to orbit
asteroids or other small bodies in the
solar system we have to take into
account the fact that at every different
point in that spacecraft's orbit it is
experiencing a slightly different
gravitational acceleration from the
asteroid because the asteroid shape is
not perfectly uniform and spherical yeah
so the gravitational constant of the
universe stays the same no matter where
you are but the distribution of mass and
how far away you are from that
distribution affects the gravitational
force you feel all the time you got it
let me ask you this is there any uh part
of astrophysics where the answer is Ah
that's good enough
yes yes
are so precise my my thesis committee
said precisely that when whether or not
they wanted to grip and give me my PhD
close enough that's terrible stop it you
stop that now continuing with
um a kind of bound and slightly
geophysical
approach David Williams has asked both
Neil and Chuck how far do you predict
the tectonic plates will move or churn
before tectonic activities stop on Earth
and you'll be dead that's the answer
no yeah so Charles let me offer you a
fast back of the envelope yeah go for it
okay so Mars
has is it 1 8 our surface area is that
right um roughly roughly I think roughly
1 8 our surface area and generally you
radiate the heat through your surface
okay Mars has no tectonic activity we
think it may have at one point but it's
completely cooled
so I'm just wondering maybe we have to
be around eight times as long as Mars
has been to reach the state that Mars is
in right now or whenever Mars had
stopped its activity what do you think
of that back in the envelope I think
that makes a lot of sense uh the the
general consensus right now is that
Mars's tectonic activity stopped about
one to two billion years I believe after
it Formed which means that we have
somewhere between say 10 and 20 billion
years worth of tectonics going on Yeah
in our Earth before you run out of
internal heat if we do that right now
we're at about four and a half billion
so the
tectonic plates currently move at about
the rate at which your fingernails grow
that is an inch or two per year so if
you go a couple inches a year and you go
for 15. you've never been to a black
Salon that nails grow way faster there
yeah they can grow in as quick as uh
five to seven minutes
yeah a little bit of glue and you're all
right
thank you for providing me that extra
option walked in looking like Nubs
walked out looking like Freddy Krueger
wow
well uh yeah so if you go in a couple
inches a year for about 15 billion years
uh then that's a pretty fair distance
you could travel now the caveat of
course as we all know Neil um and Chuck
and Gary is that 5 billion years from
now the Sun is going to go red giant and
the solar system and the entire Milky
Way is going to crash into the Andromeda
galaxy right so by then I don't think
tectonics will be an issue yeah so yeah
there you go so how would you like to
die go ahead yeah but it also means just
to be clear if you if they take tectonic
if Earth cools off there's no volcanoes
right there's no earthquakes there's no
none of that that's right there's
nothing of fire all that ends yeah
that's right and what mountains continue
to be to grow and they'd be an end the
end of mountains of everything right
okay well you could just look at Mars to
sort of see what happens once there's no
more plate tectonics right or the moon
for example
um they have these things and they sit
there and they're big and they just
don't ever change right all right okay
on that cheerful note
um boring the next question comes from
Captain James Reilly so
um I'm guessing that's the title we
should appreciate why don't we have a
deep sea base yet if we want to for
alien worlds we've got some right here
and that we just seem to be not
interested so he's encouraging now come
on Elon let's go to the bottom of the
ocean I'm saying Elon it's more of James
Cameron thing isn't it I bet Charles and
I agree on this but I'm going to lead
off and Charles you I'm going to hand
you the Baton please it is way easier to
go into space than to the bottom of the
ocean yeah Chief Charles left my hand
off to you it is not necessarily way
easier it is easier in some ways and
harder in other ways to go into space
compared to being the bottom of the
ocean but I believe that the main reason
we haven't gone down as much as we've
gone up is because there are uh shall we
say social and political advantages to
going up as opposed to going down if you
want The High Ground
and companies and and corporations and
countries are always looking for The
High Ground
you don't go down to the bottom of the
ocean you go up into orbit you go up
into space well okay but however in uh
the second world war the logaround was
the realm of submarines and so who do
you think made a bigger difference the
submarines or the airplanes yeah the
airplanes for sure yeah all right
depends on which movie you're watching
you know
Red October yeah Crimson Tide we got
them all
thank you
but uh but so what are the Charles what
are the pressures at the Marianas Trench
wow well let's see every time you go
down about 32 feet is equivalent of one
Earth atmosphere oh my Surface oh my God
so if you go down 35
000 feet that's more than a thousand
atmospheres so that's 15
000 pounds per square inch right and the
difference between one atmosphere in
space is one atmosphere
right so so there is a structural that's
kind of my point about the space is a
little structurally race is not trying
to crush you like a grape
and yet we have sent
things down into the Marianas Trench and
it has they have come back okay so
they're flatter when they come back but
right guys we're gonna take a quick
break quick break when we come back more
start talk Cosmic queries sports edition
and Gary promises us we're gonna get to
some sports questions
yes when we return on StarTalk
we're back star talk sports edition
Cosmic queries grab bag I got Charles
Lou with me uh Charles what projects are
you working on now oh this is quite a
year for me thank you for asking um
scientifically uh we're about to launch
into a lot of work with my jwst James
Webb Space Telescope and Ruben
Observatory colleagues got some projects
that are right up now so you can talk to
us when as as developments continue to
roll off the uh you know roll out the
assembly pleasure uh and I'll be talking
a little bit about that too in season
two of my podcast the universe with Dr
Charles Lou which will be dropping soon
oh my God all right the Universe I love
it love it
we're all fine podcasts are found indeed
yeah all right all right let's keep
going Gary what do you got okay I can't
do this name as much justice as Chuck
but I'll I'll have a gun in it Alejandro
[Music]
he wishes us well and has a question how
the weather affects a football match for
example when it's snowing is there
anything players can do to compensate so
the the natural elements uh of affecting
an outdoor game
the NFL's gotten wimpy because they they
always put the Super Bowl which takes
place in January February in some
Southern Climate the Super Bowls were
always held in warm climates before they
had internal stadiums
NFL championship games right the the
very famous One a long time ago Green
Bay Packers uh you know the Bart Starr
he's like crushed up and he looks old
and stuff what was it was a Super Bowl
it was Snowball that they there was a
Super Bowl held at um in New Jersey one
time not too long ago they tried to do
that didn't work out so well uh of
course uh Peyton Manning was crushed
34-8 I'm so sorry to say although he did
in fact eventually get a Super Bowl win
later with the Devon Broncos so you know
he retired out anyway too much too much
too much okay yes if you have a problem
with the weather you have to adapt uh if
it's American football right you have to
throw the ball a little bit shorter a
little bit faster if you are running the
ball uh then you have to wear different
shoes or you have to change your step a
little bit there's lots of things that
you have to make adjustments for uh the
ball's not as not as sticky when it's
harder right it's harder surface it's
harder to move and it's almost as if it
were safe
yeah that's some of the air out yeah you
know why it took you that long to get
there really why not no well no but but
Charles it's it's Automotive yes all
right in Winter whatever was the
pressure in your tires yes uh it drops
just automatically because it drops a
little bit it drops a little bit so you
have to put extra air in your tires over
the winter to maintain your standard
tire pressure I presumed in the in the
football they got to put more air in to
get the same uh was it six to nine
pounds of pressure per square inch or
whatever that is yeah you you do and and
as a result you know the way you inflate
or deflate a football uh depending on
the temperature or whatnot or whether
the quarterback likes it this way or
that um
right and and that's not allowed okay
it's not allowed there's a range and if
you want to exceed that range and and
because you know you uh want to have an
advantage or you feel better throwing
the ball or catching the ball you're not
allowed to do that that's just not part
of the rules but yes you have to make
adaptations as a player too and uh if
you're a non-us football player I don't
know how often you play in the snow but
I can only imagine how hard it is to
play in the snow there yeah I mean if
it's fresh snow Charles uh what they do
is they they clear the lines on the
field so as you can see the lines but
they'll invariably leave the snow as
long as it doesn't get too deep but
there is a kind of guideline can the
ball roll through the snow so if it if
the snow's compacted and it can roll
over the top then they'll play if it's
too deep they won't play if it for
instance if it's really windy you will
not keep the ball too high in the air
because it's more at the mercy of the
prevailing winds so the so if providing
there's no snow involved you would keep
the ball on the surface and not get it
up too much if you think it's going to
be like wet or snowy then and it's not
too windy then you get it Airborne more
because then it doesn't get stuck
getting caught in the in the hospital
totally okay it's adapt and survive it's
a it's a print it's a simple principle
you change the style of game you have to
accommodate for the the weather
so so
um one of our producers for this segment
Lane uh both she and I not at the same
time because I'm like way older uh we
both rode and one of the things we know
when we're rowing uh you've seen rowers
on the river perhaps the as the aura
goes into the water they do what's
called they feather the blade so the
blade goes into the water comes out and
it gets feathered so that when it moves
backwards against the air it reduces the
air friction and then it feathers back
and then goes in so this rotation of the
Blade is to reduce air resistance
however if you have a Tailwind you don't
feather yes the blades then become
yourself yes yes so they're tactical uh
changes that you invoke depending on on
how this works and if you're in
Wisconsin on a lake then you you don't
go anywhere because you run froze you
run frozen solid get your skates out
that's right so the other the other
thing Neil is um if you're a track and
field athlete and you're a thrower
and there's a crosswind
you then use that but you have to use it
to throw into so as it then brings you
back into the center of the The Arc that
you're possibly but the discus actually
famously goes farther into the wind than
yeah
um than With the Wind so because it it's
it becomes an airfoil and it coasts on
the up the uplift with javelins no I
mean I don't think so yeah I don't think
so no I've had the experience of
throwing Javelin so I got caught in a
crosswind and it was just listening Mr
Olympic Athlete listening not Olympic
athletes when I threw a javelin yes when
I when I stepped out of the Grecian urn
when I was modeling for the creation
Greek potterers gave me him leave so
that I could that's right didn't protect
my modesty
all right give me some more here let's
have another question here
um all right this this is from Bill
Williamson and greetings from Essexville
Michigan Williamson
yes
all right survival programs and
competitions have occupied a special
niche in American TV for a while by
survival here I mean programs such as
alone not Survivor it's a rather long
question
um let's see um
I can't recall hearing anyone talk about
how expertise in physics might shape a
contestant's choices of survival gear
um once watched Les Stroud light a fire
with a parabolic mirror that he
fashioned from the bottom of an aluminum
can
that that little shroud is superhuman
right so that guy now the one the the
curiosity now comes uh what non-standard
survival gear or preparations would us
as gentlemen
uh might take to demonstrate the value
of scientific knowledge and know-how in
the survival situation
um so okay look at this
we're stuck somewhere we don't want to
be so we need to navigate we quite need
water for survival we'll need food wait
are we naked like Naked and Afraid
I hope not but it doesn't survival that
matters right because yeah you want okay
so here we go be good if we had a
Sextant we could navigate our way out of
a bit of or knowledge of uh astronomy so
as we could possibly navigate navigate
our way out of there uh water so could
we
then generate something from
condensation
sure so so Broadway's there and then
we've got to hunt and gather we've got
to go back to stay alive and go and find
in nature what it is so a knowledge of
botany
and or the French
yeah don't eat that that'll kill you
that kind of basic stuff so what are we
saying gentlemen what could we bring
scientifically to survive in the great
unknown I would bring my smartphone that
has Uber Eats on it okay exactly all
right that's great as long as you get a
signal
I'll tell you what I'm bringing
um speaking of the long meals lines a
satellite phone that's what I'm bringing
okay and that's good and I'm good to go
come get me that's it did you see that
FedEx commercial that was a riff on this
on what's that movie that Tom Hanks was
in uh
oh
just a way just away
so so
there's a TV commercial for FedEx right
yeah and they showed that Tom Tom Hanks
character right delivering this FedEx
package years later to its address
because they always deliver okay oh my
God and she said and she said oh thank
you it's a little late but thank you and
he turns away but then he turns back and
said I just have to know
what was in that package and she said oh
a satellite phone some scenes oh my God
that's terrible I love it that's awesome
Maps yeah yeah that's all that was in it
so thank you that's great so I would
I I would say
um I would take a cue from the movie
that presumably was in the book as well
uh Black Stallion
okay
and in that
the the little boy who survived the the
he learned from his father he says
you always want a pocket knife yep I was
going to say I want a giant knife and a
magnifying glass yeah yeah a knife
because there's nothing on our body that
can do what a knife can do right right
and your teeth sort of but not as well
and so that would be the one tool that
if you had to have a survival Tool uh
that would help and magnifying glass
certainly you can make fire at any time
otherwise you got to do with the caveman
way which is you can still do it yeah
screw that string and sticks
right right forget that string and stuff
crap remember that right remember knife
remember remember what a knife is right
in physics it's a simple machine it's a
wedge yeah it's a very very sharp wedge
right and so uh that is physics right uh
and then what the five machines are just
while you're going five oh there's the
pulley thing there's a wheel and axle
thing yeah there's a wedge thing and
there's a lever thing
yeah right these are the five basic
machines in physics and these are
machines that will take energy invested
at one rate and it changes the rate on
the other end at which it gets invested
so the screw you left out the screw
didn't you the screw is a wedge that's
been coined that's aware so it's how you
can crank a car right yeah because
you're not strong enough to lift the car
but you could move something the
equivalent of yards in distance and then
the car moves up an inch yeah you're
right so it's all that energy to move it
and then it packed it into that one inch
so changes the ratio of invested energy
so that's right yeah yeah cool so cool
so cool yeah the knife is the thing man
and think about it think about how many
um foods that grow wild that we can't
eat because we don't have the strength
or the teeth to cut them open and a
knife just allows you to go ahead and
coconuts
you got a knife man you know you're good
to go yeah well I would also want
actually some sort of a blanket uh maybe
one of those thermal mylar based
blankets to keep myself warm see but
those are very small you can kill and
skin a bear and you've got a coat now
you got a coat yeah but but it smells
better
the blanket like these mylar blankets
the space blankets things right they're
very warm and they fit into a pocket
once you fold them up there's what they
give to the marathon runners when they
finish the race exactly whereas you know
bears are very large they don't fit in
your pocket all that easily so yeah it's
gonna take a while I'm not sure I want
to bring a knife to a bear fight
can't see that working out for me that's
not so that's not so fair all right
let's try to fit in like one last
question all right James Parish here is
uh in Birmingham Alabama picture if you
will hit it that knows for their speed
and proclivity to slide head first think
about uh Ricky Henderson or Pete Rose
for example they're at bat they hit a
little dribbler down to third Baseline
the third baseman charges in bare hands
the ball and makes a throw to the first
it is going to be a close play will our
Speedster reach first base quicker by
diving for the bag or running through
the
all right here's the physics of the
situation you will go faster if you are
running than when you are diving General
however
if you're trying to go a very short
distance very fast the dive can help if
you launch yourself with both feet off
the ground giving yourself that extra
little propulsion for that short
distance that you're Airborne before you
hit the ground
so if you are say inches away and you
want that last little extra bit go ahead
and dive but if you are trying to make
up a few feet or even a foot or
something like that keep running right
but Charles your two feet are never
together when you're running that's so
that's that's not a realistic situation
that's right so you have to find a way
if you're going to make your diet you
got to put both feet into the final
propelling push and so that's why so
that you would go faster than you would
have had you been only been pushed
forward with one foot at any given time
correct now here's the important caveat
right when we are horizontal we are a
few feet longer than when we're vertical
right so when Ricky Henderson used to
die what he was gaining the advantage of
was twofold one he would be ducking
below the tag
and so that's why that's why this is
specifically for first base that's right
second of all right second of all he's
got uh that extra two or three feet
horizontally to touch the bag with his
hands that he otherwise would have had
to do with his with his feet because you
have to stop right he used his belly uh
to slow himself down without having to
use the slide effect uh I wonder if
Ricky Henderson and some of these head
first divers actually wear like thicker
uniforms we're talking about first base
you don't have to slow down going into
first base if you're talking about first
base that's the question and our boy
knew that in the question right now this
is not avoiding a tag you're not slowing
down so you don't overrun it and and so
well how about this Charles
um there's when my head would have
reached the bag but there's when my
outstretched arms because I can extend
my arm faster than I can run that's
right so if you can coil yourself up in
such a way that you give yourself that
last two or three feet right going to
first base fine but usually it's not
think also most Runners are still
accelerating when they get to first base
right if you're running 100 yard dash
you don't actually reach your maximum
speed until later in yeah
so uh the distance from one base to
another in Major League Baseball is 90
feet right so you've got 30.
so you're still speeding up so you don't
want to cut off your acceleration by
diving once you leave your feet you're
not speeding up anymore you have to use
your body shape right your reach
whatever to compensate for the fact that
you're no longer accelerating what
Charles is saying is anyone who slides
into first base is a physics idiot
that's what he's saying that's basically
unless unless they understand the
concepts of rigid body motion and
flexible body motion and moments of
inertia in which case they could
actually gain a slight advantage
would it be advantageous to go foot feet
first in a slide rather than head and
here's here's what I'm going to say
anyone who understands uh moments of
inertia or rigid body motion is not
diving head first into your face yeah
most likely they will have already done
such a good job hitting the ball that
they would just be able to Coast into
first round the base and decide whether
or not to take second
there you go all right well thanks for
this bit of insight here and yes it
matters whether it's first space or
second uh for this question of course
but guys that's all we have time
all right guys we got to get out of this
all right Land This Plane uh it's been a
delight uh Charles Lou my friend and
colleague to join us once again
as our geek in Chief thank you so much
Gary always good to have you there
this has been a stark talk sports
edition Cosmic queries grab bag Neil
deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist keep looking up
foreign